all right guys you know the drill I'm
Mark I haven't seen this show before and
today I'll be throwing myself head first
into its manga to see how good it
actually is you guys have been
requesting this one since I covered
Hunter Hunter which I really enjoyed
even though it dragged me into a
depression the likes of which I narrowly
escaped also unlike other stories where
I've seen some iconography or I've heard
some things with yuu Haka show I knew
quite literally nothing going in it
wasn't on TV when I was growing up I
didn't know what I was about I didn't
know anyone's name I didn't even know
how to spell the name of this damn story
until about 10 minutes ago shout out to
Google you're the real one here also
also I have to not only read and review
this for the first time but I need to do
it in exactly 1 month because in 1 month
this arrives the liveaction Netflix
adaptation of YuYu Haka show and I'll be
damned if I don't get to either enjoy or
hate watch this thing with the rest of
the world so now that we're on the same
page I've got about 30 days to read to
review this series can I do it will I
enjoy it only one way to find out I'm
Mark Fitzpatrick and this is the series
that put Yoshi hero Togashi on the map a
childhood staple for many but brand new
for me this is YuYu haky
[Music]
show I can categorically say that while
some manga take a while to warm up for
me or might not be my cup of off the bat
from the moment I finished the first
chapter Togashi immediately hooked me as
a reader YuYu Haka show is incredible
and a tremendously well-written Story
the moment you open the cover you're
greeted by the first of many blurbs
Togashi decides to write it is always
weird but in the most Togashi way
possible and right out the gate I was
reacquainted with the beautifully dark
style of Storytelling Togashi has become
world famous for penic and this story
that proceedes that weird blurp while
preceding his most famous work Hunter
Hunter it is still rich with the
blueprints that led him to that very
success thrusting us into the story from
the very first page we are gripped with
Intrigue as our main character has died
what the entire opening chapter
therefore acts as a flashback to grant
us context for that very inciting
incident and through doing so Tashi
reminds us why he's one of the greats in
the manga industry sporting a
significantly more light-hearted opener
compared to that which Hunter Hunter's
corresponding chapters boast the comedy
is extremely prevalent with tons of
quick gags emphasized through expressive
and cartoonish artwork but those
familiar with togashi's work understand
that this style and approach conceals a
far darker Edge to his stories in
addition to establishing the fun
atmosphere of the story the main
character yusuke urmi's outlook on life
despite his nonchalant and delinquent
attitude is rather Bleak and from the
GetGo tagashi bondz us with him very
effectively taking the interesting
approach of him doing some minor
offenses all the While others
surrounding him count him out or degrade
him for things he hasn't done
underpinned by his young mother heavily
implied to be a prostitute hammering
home the difficult circumstances
surrounding his upbringing which
interestingly was omitted entirely from
the anime having been told time and
again that yusuke is a bad person
someone that relishes in breaking the
rules and looking out only for himself
like any great story wortht telling our
main character is then offered a moment
to reveal to us who he truly
[Applause]
is immediately he steals my heart I love
this character this is the moment that
grants us context for what actually
happened on that first page and as it
happens it's a moment that defines
yusuke as a good person in our eyes
having seen that altruistic Act of good
I am now firmly in his corner and it
only took took half a chapter for
Togashi to achieve this and he keeps
going having just learned that he's died
from hisum to be companion in this early
portion ban he reflects a level of Cal
and introspection the likes you'd never
expect from a 14-year-old and one that
only can be offered through a rough life
furthermore despite all of his sins
being called out before him the only
thing he seems concerned about in that
moment is that little kid's well-being
is he okay did he manage to save him
he's not concerned about himself these
are small tangents but they offer an
enormous amount of Goodwill from me as a
reader I love this sort of stuff and now
offered a chance to return to the land
of the living from King enma no not that
one this one we have the mechanism and
plot device that defines this early
portion of the story however following
the conclusion and established Stakes
Within These opening chapters the story
changes in a way that honestly scared me
it turned episode epic I'll be the first
one to say it as a general rule of thumb
for myself I don't really like episodic
stories I find them laborious at worst
and slightly tedious at best however
again Togashi worked his magic here and
offered me the first episodic series of
chapters I've enjoyed this much in years
whether it be the dog and his kid owner
the old man chapters or the corrupt
teachers the episodic intro to this
world despite having its fair share of
Comedy is also underpinned by tragedy
and drama
helping to frame the story stupendously
and using these segments Togashi builds
up his characters by how they react to
these peculiar circumstances and other
worldly happenings and for yusuke our
main character and kabara a similar in
kind supporting character it's fighting
both of their Natural Instincts in order
to benefit others now not to sound like
a nerd here but I'm a big fan of tests
in stories and these early chapters are
full of them the most obvious and
Central to the story being yusuke's test
offered off by Co enma but there's
several others exposing the true nature
of not just yusuke but an extended cast
of colorful characters we watch as they
are exposed to tests of Courage which
ultimately reveal the true essence of
their emerging characters and by the
time I reached the conclusion to these
opening episodic chapters I found myself
not just hooked by a gripping narrative
but connected to and invested in the
extended cast most notably kabara and I
thought I was going to hate this guy but
he turned out to be one of the
highlights for me if not the highlight
of these opening chapters revealed
initially as a less skilled less
intelligent and less everything version
of yusuke I thought he was a thug and
nothing more something for us to see the
differences in yusuke with but then he
got his own chapter in it a snobbish and
frighteningly belligerent teacher
threatens one of his friends very job a
job they need to help their family make
ends meet and with the only way way to
prevent this from happening being to not
fight for one week and score at least
50% in the upcoming science test
kuwabara's other friends are no bright
Sparks but they have grades that make
achieving such a feat relatively easy
but kabara doesn't on top of that he's
notorious around the city meaning that
not only does he have to find a way to
learn the material but also has to
endure Savage beatings without
retaliation for the sake of his friends
and he does just that in a single
chapter Togashi made me 180 my opinions
on this character now he's arguably my
favorite it's a terrific chapter
probably my favorite out of the early
material and the way yusuke watches all
of this unfold with his own commentary
is the icing on top and that's what it
got me thinking on one hand the nature
of this episodic format can offer a ton
of advantages to a newly released manga
without an audience to read your new
material it serves your story rather
well early on to not require prior
knowledge of the story when you flip
past a chapter in Shonen Jump would be
future fans could just happen upon any
of these early chapters and be caught up
in their self-contained stories all the
while slowly being immersed in the
greater narrative or World however like
with any story I think it's quite Brave
to release effectively two volumes worth
of manga without an emerging narrative
through line the idea of yusuke getting
his body back is obviously the main
point of interest for the narrative but
it doesn't really feel at the Forefront
of the story it's a sort of thin vessel
a hook to keep us invested as he offers
us a boatload of really thorough
character work for everyone and I think
this is why you often see a thousand
threads like when does it get good for
people attempting the anime I'm a stupid
[__] with an ugly face and a big butt
but I really like it as a choice with
the manga's pacing funnily enough and
like I said there are two whole volumes
worth of these episodic type exploits so
in the interest of time let's lightning
round these bad boys the Saka stuff is
cute with how it carries on the story of
the dog kid from earlier I expected it
to be fairly straightforward with yusuke
taking on a raging ghost but the
subversion by essentially killing it
with kindness was rather refreshing it
turns out you don't need to beat people
up who would have thought in the next
story there's a two chapter stretch
dedicated to two girls that are both
friends and academic Rivals uh and I
didn't really like it it felt a bit too
much like an after school special with
its straightforward moral messaging and
without yusuke really learning anything
here like in previous chapters it's all
a bit I don't know fillery to me at the
very least it introduces some added
texture to the way Spirits can function
within this world but I don't know how
relevant that'll be going forward the
next piece of story I absolutely adored
was the chapter of sayaka judging yusuke
and koo's relationship the whole thing
is utterly adorable but what I find
super interesting is how Togashi is
somehow making me root so hard for these
two despite their primary direct
interaction being a few panels at the
start normally this would work against a
lesser writer but but not to gashi
instead he leverages the unique setting
of his world and bunks all the
conventions in the process it's all of
this indirect intervention from both
sides that creates the unique Bond they
share interestingly enough she looks
after him from The Real World Al while
he protects her from the spirit realm
it's a fantastically written romance and
a unique one at that after that we get a
story about K saving yusuke's body from
an arsonist but what I noticed about
this story was something very much
second AR to the main plot Koo does
demonstrate tremendous courage in that
moment and I love her emerging character
but we get a little more from kabara
here too it's interesting how he's
slowly being integrated into the actual
story we had his setup and initial
characterization and now we're seeing
him come running to help and take in Koo
after the fire we're really starting to
get a clearer picture of this
well-rounded character he actually is
with him very much being an analog to
yusuke in every respect and finally
there's another double chapter Story
chronicling yusuke's Mission to help
this little kid win a box in match it's
sweet but again at this point it's
starting to feel like directionless
filler yusuke isn't learning anything
here he's just teaching at this point it
was definitely the time for the
narrative to reemerge now that were two
volumes deep and tagashi must have been
listening to me because it
[Music]
does with the first two volumes
effectively introducing us to the story
and its characters through episodic
means while it was fun it is now time to
get into YuYu Haku show proper a full
dedicated narrative free of the
constraints presented by the episodic
formulation and that means it's demon
hunting time and with the looming demon
hunt comes the introduction of a series
of interesting tools and gadgets to help
you navigate his upcoming challenges
right off the bat early on he's given
this eyeglass which helps him see
through obstructions and I think that
given his first instinct wasn't to
portray the trust of every single female
in the premises goes to show what kind
of good boy he is deep down and that the
only reason he lifted koo's dress up in
the first place was because he knew it
bothered her and he wanted to tease her
in addition to that he's given the demon
Compass it's pretty self-explanatory
it's a compass that points towards the
bad guys and finally my favorite the r
gun or spirit gun it is freaking awesome
but I think interestingly the way it's
implemented tells us a lot about yusuke
and reinforces my early claim that
Togashi really understands how to drag
the most out of his characters in these
sorts of stories the first major
technique our protagonist learns
traditionally comes through a certain
amount of trial and error training one
where they prove their worth and
demonstrate the Merit of their character
by pushing themselves far beyond where
others would but yusuke just does it
he's told how to and he does it
immediately however there is more to
this and it's a brilliant decision the
technique is given a limit it can only
be used once per day and I think that is
utterly perfect for someone like yusuke
nothing about his story thus far has
presented him as this trainy or novice
type character he simply is who he is
Win Lose or Draw and he doesn't lose
often let me tell you that he's not like
a Naruto or even really an Ichigo for
that matter he's naturally good at quite
a lot when it comes to the physical and
spiritual nature of things so what did
Togashi do to combat this supposed
problem well he targeted yusuke's
greatest
weakness this is the first time yusuke
shoots his ray gun as audience members
were entranced by this new flashy move
and the Swagger or main character
exhibits using it and personally I was
quite delighted because that de call had
a coming but little did we know that
Togashi had granted yusuke a technique
that forced him to grow as a character
one that targets his greatest weakness
his rash decision making his inability
to think before he acts the ray gun will
only fire once per day no matter what he
does right now no matter how gifted he
might be physically he won't be able to
fire it more than once at least not
right now and knowing this he still
decides to shoot it at someone who while
deserving of it wasn't posing an
immediate threat he simply did it for
shortterm satisfaction how do I know
that Togashi designed this move to do
just that well because of the very next
fight you finds himself in moments
[Music]
later narratively this scene is cool as
all hell because yusuke is wandering up
to these three notorious demonic targets
like he's the one they should be worried
about I mean seriously you can't teach
this level of swagger it's infectious
but what I loved about this scene is
that despite putting up a terrific fight
for a 14-year-old kid yusuke loses to
this giant bruising soul sucking demon
decisively it wasn't even close and it
wasn't close in part because he wasted
his best attack on something that didn't
matter waking up from his loss and on
conscious State ban offers him a ring
that boosts his Ray gun's power and now
armed with that lesson learned yusuke
finds that demon and puts him to bed the
fight is awesome it has its ups and
downs for the young kid but God damn
does he keep it cool under pressure and
execute cunning strategy on the Fly
exceptionally well this is exactly the
sort of development I want to see from
this main character it's exceptionally
good thanks to the mechanics of the ray
gun yusuke is in the process now of
learning one of the most valuable
lessons anyone can learn to put off
short-term satisfaction in order to
reach long-term goals it's an
exceptionally strong creative writing
choice for tagashi both visually and
mechanically for this character utter
Perfection now of course go is but one
of three and with this being the first
segment of the series telling a
substantial multi-chapter story I was
excited but largely expecting similar
feeling battles that test yusuke's
abilities and well it turns out tagashi
managed to subvert both my expectations
and my understanding of what demons can
be in this story you see when you think
of monstrous Demons of the Underworld
the design of gouki with all his
ruthless personality traits is pretty
much the deao image that comes to mind
and yet Kurama could not be more
different his design is welcoming and
his speech cam his approach when meeting
yusuke is not one of aggression but
instead a plea quote give me 3 days then
I will return the mirror I just love how
off-kilter that feels in contrast to
what we've seen so far and upon learning
that the mirror will grant your deepest
desire in exchange for a mystery
offering it's a double whammy of
gripping Intrigue pulling from Japanese
mythology as the series so loves to do
it turns out that Kurama is actually a
fox spirit with ties to the nine Tales
and he was forced into the vessel of a
human baby after a narrow escape from a
bounty hunter what follows is a
spectacularly well- told tale of a
spirit who learned to love his surrogate
human mother as he grew up in the human
world who saw the sacrifices made and
developed unwavering empathy in the
process so yeah kurama's human mother is
dying and he needs that mirror to save
her M like what a hook and yet only if a
few pages later it's revealed the
offering the mirror requires in return
is his own life this all takes place
across a single chapter and yet it's one
of the most powerful so far I think in
only a few short Pages contained within
one character Togashi has added Nuance
to the Demon World by producing a
character with a motivation completely
antithetical to that which preceded him
in different incarnations while also
introducing and bonding us to the
character of Kurama and as the chapter
comes to a a close Togashi links it all
back to yusuke as Kurama is about to
give up his life for his mother yusuke
steps in and offers part of his own
lifespan to save his calling back to the
very start of the story quote you ever
see a mother despairing over her Lost
Child I mean wow that is some seriously
outstanding writing and what a way to
flip my idea of the Demonic Outlaws on
its head tagashi is an outstanding
character writer and one that really
knows how to tug on your heartstrings in
a very effective manner that just leaves
us with one remaining Relic
unfortunately this seems like the point
that yusuke is most likely to run into a
brick wall as it is held by the small
but extremely menacing he that name is I
wasn't sure how to pronounce I hope I'm
nailing it uh can I buy a
consonant even from the GetGo it's being
clear that he is the real threat of the
trio Togashi has proven time and again
that he loves subverting visual EXP
expectation so naturally the smallest
and weakest looking of the trio is going
to be the most dangerous worse still he
holds the most menacing relic of them
all a sword that can turn someone into a
demon with even a single neck from the
moment heets his eyes on yusuke the up
Stakes are set out very clearly with the
chapter itself opening with an
illustrative panel of he and his blade
in front of an unconscious or dead Koo
and what's more is he doesn't wait
around for the plot either nearly
interrupting a cute exchange between ban
and Koo he immediately swoops in slashes
her and takes her hostage Togashi skips
right on past Damsel in the stress and
Leap Frog straight into damsel has
already been slashed by the demon blade
and is in the process of becoming
herself a demon that sort of jump in
Stakes is an excellent way to further
drive home how much more of a threat
this final foe really is with Koo
already struck by The Sword and he a
very clearly outclassing yusuke in every
every possible measure for the first
time yusuke is forced to face a
situation that is from the looks of it
truly completely impossible and I love
that this sort of impossible pressure is
pure golden fiction and presents
infinite possibilities with squeezing
out excellence and character from our
heroes and then he announces loudly and
plainly that there is a literal antidote
to the demonization in the hilt of his
blade and also suddenly yusuke is faster
and stronger than
him okay let's take a step back and
reintroduce hi this is hi he's a [__]
I'm a stupid [__] King of the tiny
morons who does things like announc the
only weakness in his plan to the hero
and gets beaten up by the regular
14-year-old middle schooler despite
being an actual real life superpowered
demon himself he is the sort of villain
that will look us dead in the eyes and
unironically utter the line so you're
the sword who raises to the occasion
when a friend isn't need I am so so
bummed out how this first big encounter
played out Togashi really had in an
incredibly efficient amount of time mind
you built up here as yusuke's first real
big threat and backed yusuke into a
corner that was ripe for excitement but
then when the time came it's almost like
tagashi couldn't quite come up with a
satisfying way for yusuke to overcome
these obstacles because it seemed to be
impossible and just said [__] it we ball
now I'll admit there is a very
entertaining element to seeing yusuke
just TRS through most of this fight by
sheer will of puny alone seeing yusuke
literally threaten to wall up he is just
full of the exaggerated Swagger of a
Japanese teen but it's just it just
undercuts everything Tashi had built up
so immediately why would you literally
announce an antidote why is yusuke who
is again at this point a regular
14-year-old Punk able to keep up with
and [__] an inhumanely fast demon all
right I'm stun locking myself
okay anyway he transforms into
biblically accurate he and uses some
Demon magic to stop yusuke from moving
thankfully our old friend Kurama is able
to jump in at a critical moment and make
a save throwing the demon version of
pocket sand into he's big old eyeball
pocket sand with this yusuke is able to
start trading blows with he for a bit
before losing his upper hand and being
once again backed into a corner with
only one trick left up his sleeve he
fires a powerful ray gun at who Dodges
it I was not expecting that Dodge and
that rug pull felt super reminiscent to
me of aeta managing to dodge the geni
dhama in the Sean Arch that sort of oh
[__] what now moment works amazingly
well here and given that said geni dama
chapter released just two years prior to
this with Togashi also very clearly a
fan of Toriyama I would actually be
surprised if that wasn't what he was
going for here so where Dragon Ball had
Gohan rise up against his previous fear
and reflect col the ball back toward
Vegeta how does yusuke manage here well
as it turns out yusuke was actually
aiming for the mirror Relic rather than
he himself how did that mirror get there
we never saw but it's there and as it
also turns out the mirror is able to
reflect back the spirit gun or Ray Gun
how did yusuke know this well he didn't
he says so himself and as it also also
turns out yusuke had scurried to a spot
that happened to roughly line up with
where the mirror reflected to allowing
it to direct ly hit he from behind and
with that he is down at the end of it
all yusuke even explains pretty clearly
to Bowen that he didn't really have any
plan or reason for the whole maneuver
and that it just happened to work out
it's a sort of that's the joke moment
and all credit to Tashi by the end of it
all I found the whole thing so
ridiculous that I was actually laughing
along at the utter absurdity of it all
it definitely wasn't a fight that I
actively disliked reading though but
what it was is a shining example of how
new took Togashi was to all this
specifically all this action manga
business by the time Hunter Hunter had
rolled around Togashi had honed his
Craft on this front to the point where
Hunter Hunter is one of the Premier most
well-crafted battle Shonen arguably in
existence so it is really fascinating on
an academic level for me to see the
beginnings of that to see Togashi albeit
very clumsily finding his footing and
learning lessons in the world of
plotting an action Monga specifically
and as a bonus I have now mentally put a
world dumbest Gremlin Post-It note on
he's face so that's fun gen Kai's
tournament by stark contrast the
following Arc is absolutely my favorite
stuff I've read thus far and a major
contrast to the less serialized stuff i'
come to expect from this story until now
from start
to almost finish it was completely my
jam and exactly the sort of Arc this
story needed full of humor action story
and Misadventures we were thrown into
the arc pretty unexpectedly as we
quickly learned that yusuke is attending
a competition to become a powerful Reiki
Master's Apprentice mainly because an
evil ability stealing demon named Rando
yep that's his name is also vying for
that very spot which is not good I've
heard the twist however is that we have
absolutely no idea who Rando
is this curveball added to an already
compelling situation creates a
captivating Mini game of sorts for
readers like me to partake in now we the
readers are the spirit detectives trying
to sus out who the Incognito demon may
be along with our heroes and even
without that the trials of Master gen
Kai's potential Apprentice are quickly
underway and rather unusual no tests of
skill or will just drawing Lots though
it's played as a gag at first it really
serves to establish some of the wisdom
and trickery that Genai is capable of as
she has treated the individual lots to
read to the those with spiritual
potential it's clever stuff really the
second trial is equally odd having the
remaining contestants play some
spiritually related games a punching
machine to test physical prowess a
karaoke machine to test Life Energy or
whatever that means and a digital rock
paper scissors machine to test their six
senses this whole round of games is not
only a fun read but does a lot of heavy
lifting in terms of finally beginning to
flesh out the mechanical systems of this
world now can finally begin to have
explanations for things like why can
these teenagers 14year olds punch so
damn hard and with both yusuke and the
tagalan kurabara progressing through
this round we advance to the forest
section having read Hunter Hunter long
before even knowing this material
existed it's remarkable how much of this
Forest section feels like the blueprint
of the forest section from the hunter
exams themselves despite that it's
taking a very different approach the
hunter exam Forest section was gripping
in the tension it established so much
time was spent there with the very real
threat of death looming on the horizon
for all who participated particularly
considering the presence of a particular
killer clown on the flip side this
Incarnation is far lighter and humorous
by Design and it's kind of interesting
how Tori coded some of this material
actually feels much of the humor
wouldn't feel out of place with
character designs like batm even feeling
evocative of the early Dragon Ball
Rogues Gallery we grew to love at the
time but even with it being lighter it
still manages to do some great work in
further fleshing out our heroes this
time chiefly with kabara while yusuke
does manage to make it in time by the
skin of his teeth demonstrating his
physical prowess by beating the
strongest threat in the whole Forest
along the way the spotlight here is
really on kurabara further establishing
his niche as someone with an incredible
six sense I mean my boy kabara arrives
first place mind you strolling through
the entire thing in no time flat in
these types of challenges you often
expect the main character to blow the
potential Master Away by acing every
single challenge in an unexpected
fashion but not here I was grinning a
smile the Grinch would be envious of
from ear to ear when kabara emerged from
that Forest did I mention he came first
what a Chad now at this point because
Genai expected only one to make it
through the forest the final eight have
to partic ipate in a small impromptu
tournament for the grand prize and you
best believe I was trying my best to
find out who the impostor was there was
even a point where I was wondering if
kabara was the impostor himself maybe
that might explain why he's doing so
well but by far the more obvious
apparent candidates at this time were
certainly the Assassin guy and the mangi
guy both acing their trials and carrying
with them an air of Mystique however I
am Simply Built different I wasn't going
to let some silly obvious answer or fool
me the professional Manga Reader me H I
figured that those two had to be
misdirections and after this page
specifically I was very convinced that
this random ball kid was in fact Rando
not because he's the least imposing like
I touched on though that's also valid
but particularly because if you look at
this page for a moment you'll notice he
is actually the only participant who
doesn't get his own panel for his
introduction that sort of let's not pay
attention to this guy paneling screams
impostor to me I was so confident and
could not wait to see if I was right
spoiler alert your boy was
congratulations you played yourself
I'm but overall everything before the
tournament itself felt as though Togashi
used his own clairvoyancy to look into
the future and directly respond to my
annoyance at the last few chapters
addressing the roots of many of my
criticisms expanding the world laying
foundations for the Power Systems of the
story and helping me to car more about
the extended cast what had started as an
upbeat series of spiritual challenges
has devolved into a much more serious
and dark sequence of death matches I
don't think anything reflects togashi's
writing style better and it's cool to
reflect back on how this same transition
occurred in the hunter exams Kudo versus
kazim Maru fittingly the first of these
quarterfinal matchups feature two new
faces in order to establish the
Benchmark for what's expected in this
tournament as well as the scale of power
these new foes boast shrouded in
darkness we barely see this fight with
the focus instead being on kuab Bar's
heightened perception as he takes it all
in while nobody else can and what's more
is kazim Maru serves up a ray gun from
his Pam that eclipse is the best we've
seen yusuke produce suddenly our main
character isn't the most perceptive nor
is he the most powerful Kaz Maru emerges
Victorious having narrowly killed his
opponent and with that the tone Chang is
super apparent Shaolin or Shin for those
who only know the dub defeats his
opponent offc screen another hint hint
as to who he is and with that we have
our first matchup with one of our heroes
kabara versus moushi this is another
great showing for kabara while his
ability to sense things has been at the
Forefront of this Arc so far this fight
also emphasizes his capacity to remain
Cam and collected in battle despite
moushi cloaking his Aura to avoid
kuwabara's attack kabara perseveres
eventually using a fragment of his
enemy's weapon to create an aura sword
this level of improvisation is awesome
to see as a reader and it impresses Gen
Kai too kabara wins as a result leading
us onto what is in my opinion the best
yusuke fight so far urameshi versus kibo
God I love this fight from the moment
this fellow was introduced on a page
early on in this Arc he stood out not
just in terms of his design but
additionally in how naturally strong he
is where kuara was able to carve out his
own Niche against his own opponent
yusuke is put up against someone who is
just better than him he had a better
punching back score he reached the
finish line of the forest first each
step of this tournament has purposely
Illustrated how much better kibo is than
yusuke even in his own strengths and
that disparity despite taking place in
the pitch black is certainly illuminated
in the opening exchanges not as
perceptive as kabara yusuke is fighting
entirely blind all the well kibo carries
out his actions like a future
incarnation of the yusuke character
might one who has honed his abilities to
overcome his weaknesses backing yusuke
into a corner like this with no obvious
road to success it created the perfect
opportunity to surprise me as an
audience member
[Applause]
reading this is Cinema and I love it
because the seeds were planted long
before the fight even began yusuke keeps
track of kibbo all the while leveraging
his strength and ability against him
using his cigarette it's one of the most
clever creative combative writing
choices in this series is totally in
line with his character and furthers
UK's path in becoming a fighter that's
capable of planning ahead absolutely the
best fight in this entire video Don't at
me do people still say that or did it
change because Elon changed it to X I
don't know kazim Maru versus ureshi
sadly this standard of combat writing
couldn't last and following it we get
one of the weakest fights from this
tournament with Darkness removed
projectiles are fair game again allowing
for death stars to be thrown and for
yusuke to have to navigate them there's
a bit of Doubt surrounding urmi's
ability to fire a decisive blow via the
ray gun or not but ultimately the fight
concludes with yusuke coming out on top
in a very unsatisfying fashion good
oldfashioned pure dumb luck my least
favorite means of ending a fight Shaolin
versus kabara I enjoyed this fight and I
think it conveyed what it needed to
establishing Shaolin as Rando see how
smart I am and the sadistic offbeat
nature he brings to each encounter he
engages in but what it also highlighted
for me was a missed opportunity I
complimented the inclusion of this
mystery element into the story tasking
the audience to try to solve for who
Rando was masquerading as but what it
also highlighted for me was a missed
opportunity I complemented the inclusion
of this mystery element into the story
earlier tasking the audience to try and
solve for who Randle was masquerading as
and while obvious to a certain extent if
you know what to look for that is it's
not how easy it was to figure out that
was disappointing to me it was how
nothing of a role this Rando thread
played in the story up until this very
Point despite being one of the primary
reasons Yus is there in the first place
outside of that he doesn't really offer
much to this story at all on until this
very moment despite us not seeing
anything in the forest section really I
thought it could have afforded Togashi
an opportunity to implement some Rando
shenanigans that he could have through
the cloak of the forest done something
to better tie him to the story perhaps
he might have killed people along the
way maybe he almost kills yusuke causing
him to almost miss the cut off time
nothing happens with the character until
his mask off moment to the point that
yusuke jokes part ways through that he
forgot why he was even there in the
first place
it's a cool reveal but I can't help but
feel that the mystery felt a bit of a
waste up until then if you ask me in the
moment however I think this fight or
rather beat down achieves exactly what
it needed to kabara is a character that
Togashi bonded us to quite effectively
across this series thus making him the
perfect sacrificial lamb for Rando in
order to fire up yusuke and Us by
association and boy was Juke fired
up
[Applause]
[Music]
urameshi versus Rando without warning a
vengeful yusuke lashes out towards Rando
Landing a massive punch right out the
gate after all he did to kabara and all
the torture he served up with that
unsettlingly detached attitude there was
something enormously cathartic about
yusuke just getting to beat the piss out
of this guy at will and to be honest
most of the offense here makes sense a
consistent point of commentary and
criticism over rando's fights offered by
Genai herself has been how long his
attacks take to wind up leaving him open
to use's natural and quick striking
nature unfortunately the final fight
once again Falls a bit flat for me
perhaps it's meant to be endearing but
save for the kibbo fight earlier every
other time yusuke has won an encounter
it has been due in little to no part to
his own ability or strategy having just
survived the fall into deadly Waters
while wrapped in Aura webs yes that's an
accurate sentence that reflects this
story perfectly and after receiving a
pep talk from kabara yusuke wins through
again sheer dumb luck against HEI it was
the luck of a mirror reflection with
kazemaru he happened to fall into a bog
at the exact right time and this time he
had algae in his ears to prevent vent
him from hearing rando's incantation I'm
sorry what Algae has this happened to I
don't know anyone ever this is coming
from someone who lives in a literal bog
I'm from Cork in the south of Ireland
the name cork in Irish is kir and that
literally translates to bog I'm from the
boglands Alie does not get into your
ears like that it just doesn't happen
it's a real bummer and only further
serves to emphasize how brilliant
yusuke's fight against kibo was earlier
and that's the end of the arc yusuke is
genkai's new pupil I loved 99% of this
Arc tagashi just needs to brush up on
how he concludes fights in satisfying
ways Lord knows he has it in him he
demonstrated it here hopefully he
continues this trend the four beasts
it's funny after all the trials and
tribulations yusuke just went through to
win the position of gen Kai's pupil
you'd naturally expect a train arch of
some description to follow I was all
prepped for a Luke Skywalker and Yoda
training segment and instead got Goku
getting to kyo's Planet only to
offscreen the entire thing instead
Togashi decides to hard cut us to two
weeks later with kabara healed yusuke
returning home and a whole new
world-ending threat on hand turns out a
group of demons called the four beasts
are trying to break down the barrier
between the demon city and the human
world by infesting people with parasitic
demon things that turn them into
murderous psychos and as it happens the
only way to stop them is to eliminate
the enabling whistle that allows them to
exist in the Mortal realm boom setup
done and now a hard cut to the enemy
base so jarring that even tokashi
himself makes a joke of it in the gutter
of a panel miraculously Kurama and hi
are here doing community service and so
tagashi has essentially done a speedrun
through all the party Gathering early
game content and dropped us flashbang in
the midst of the final dungeon and I do
not use that video game terminology for
no reason because Togashi loves games
we've already seen as much with the mini
games in the previous Arc and fans of
Hunter Hunter don't need me to bring up
Greed Island to tell you that for all
intents and purposes this four Beast Arc
is a video game both in terms of its
structure scaling a tower of mini bosses
to reach the final but also the way the
fights are written themselves the
villains here are based on the four
Lords of Chinese mythology with the the
first battle taking place between Kurama
and genbu mechanically genbu can
disappear into the environment forcing
Kurama to search for TS and yet despite
that his strongest attacks do nothing
except until Kurama targets his literal
glowing energy core video games am I
right while this definitely had the
potential to be interesting the lack of
any real setup to the core weakness
being discovered leads to it suffering
the same sort of convenient resolution I
criticized in the previous Arc
thankfully however the next Bel between
BYO and kurabara doesn't suffer that
same fate at all and man does a dial up
that video game inspiration to 11 the
boss itself spawns mobs and kurabara
sure does struggle until wait for it he
funnels the pack down a narrow bridge
allowing him to gain the upper hand I
feel like kuara would have been one hell
of a Dark Souls player jokes aside I
actually really did enjoy the character
work here in the first phase kurabara is
such a funny contradiction of a person
his personality screams dumbass and yet
his actual perception in the midst of
battle is really strong he notices that
not only is BYO absorbing the energy
from his attacks but he has a limit also
and succeeds in overloading him phase
one down Phase 2 is the most
transparently video game of them all I
mean it's literally an acid pool with
platforms that crumble and get destroyed
by the boss if you stand on them for too
long I'm not entirely sure why the
second part of the fight exists since
there's not really any strategy or drama
here kabara straight up yeets himself at
Bako and it's over which sort of leads
me to believe that this video game
framing device and structure device for
fights itself are really more of a
crutch for Togashi than they are uh an
inspired choice to add some flavor to
battles the fight with seru and he that
follows is similarly brief but holy [__]
is it cool I mean he just one- shots the
guy which is sick in another itself but
I love what it does for he's character
he is so completely enraged by the fact
that seru murdered at pleading Bako and
Kurama notes that he sees a change in
him also perhaps brought on by yusuke
himself the little rage Gremlin is still
an enigma to me at this point but if
these are seeds being planted for a
redeeming turnaround Allah Vegeta then
I'm all in for it which brings us to
saaku the final boss and yet this isn't
video gamey at all and regretfully in a
tragic twist of fate despite the strong
outing of these three prior bouts the
yusuke fight is probably the weakest of
them but on a design front this boss
looks incredible and right from the
GetGo a bonus stake is added not only
are the parasitic demon worms taking
over but suzaku is specifically
targeting Koo now I admit I actually
groaned a little when that was first
established it's the sort of half ass
Damelin distress Trope that leads to
women being fridged but Togashi
surprised me a little bit here too
yusuke's battle is intercut with a
proper B plot surrounding Koo who sure
holds her own next to bten I mean she
straight up one punch man's a teacher
Additionally the cutaways do feel a bit
overbearing at times but the core fight
between suzaku and yusuke is Far and
Away the most dynamic and well paneled
fight so far suzaku uses lightning which
forces yusuke to think on his feet
almost literally when he puts his rubber
so shoes on his hands in what appears to
be a way to at himself against the
electric shock except wait he was
actually just using them to mass the
concentrated Aura in his fists leading
to a devastating blow the Koo cutaway
kind of confuses the impact of this move
however but I still love it as a concept
nevertheless and suzaku is sure not
hurting for strategy either he splits
himself into seven and completely
overwhelms yusuke and unfortunately this
is the part where the fight kind of
starts to fall apart for me but it falls
apart in a way that's very different
from the endings of the previous arcs
where contrivance murders the impact
this largely feels diminished because it
falls back on a Trope that is quite
dated by today's standards yusuke has a
flashback to his training with Gen Kai
of a moment where he learns to push past
his limits in the face of death and with
a vision of his friends and loved ones
fading away he Powers up beyond anything
we've seen before launching his shotgun
move and although it's not quite enough
to end the fight the cries of Koo
echoing through his mind caus to explode
in new power launching a devastating
attack on suzaku that obliterates him
and destroys the command whistle it's a
relatively cool moment but it's the
embodiment of the power of friendship
Trope that is really just so dated these
days and has never really felt
particularly satisfying or compelling
even in the context of the years in
which this device was common but as down
as I might sound I did have a great time
here if its biggest sin is that it feels
like a dated fight rather than a
Timeless one then I'm AC exceptionally
excited to see where things go from here
rescuing yukina what follows is less of
an arc and more of a Prelude to
something called The Dark Tournament
it's funny I did say at the start of
this video that I hadn't the slightest
idea what this series entailed and yet
as soon as I saw Dark Tournament written
on the page all my synapses lit up like
a Christmas tree and I realized that
this legendary tournament I'd heard so
much praise for was actually from this
series and guess what I haven't seen it
either and man given how strong this
setup Arc is I cannot put into words
just how excited I am to tackle that in
the next episode of this review Series
this Prelude begins with the gang
receiving an assignment from coena to
rescue he's sister yukina an ice Maiden
who was captured by a bastard of a human
called tarukane I feel like I'm
definitely edging ever closer to the
ruthless Togashi I know from Hunter
Hunter the cruelty in this Arc is
utterly staggering and I couldn't help
but notice togashi's author comments
begin to mention his crippling back pain
here also perhaps it's just a
coincidence but it's probably not a
stretch to suggest that his writing
becomes exceptionally dark when he's not
in a good way in his life Terra Kan is
struggling to get yukina to cry these
days so he calls in the toguro brothers
to fix things up their designs are so
unnerving one's a tall mean-faced brute
and the other a tiny creep of a man
who's perched on his shoulder Togashi
shows us that yukina's only source of
comfort in her captivity is through the
birds that visit her window and the
toguro Brother's first point of order is
to crush them right in front of her
that's horrifying enough as it is but he
goes even further with a later flashback
that shows a kind-hearted guard
ruthlessly murdered for trying to help
her things have always had a dark twist
to them in this story but this feels
like a totally different level from the
very get-go the togoro brothers have the
most menacing presence and seriously
gripped me villains up until now have
been a bit of an underwhelming weak
point in the story and yet this pair
really got to me like no other the
younger toguro weirdly the larger one
gets some proper development terane
tasks him with killing his monstrous pet
to prove his strength and yet he follows
through despite his love of animals
that's nuance and a clear idea that this
guy will follow orders no matter what
that's real setup here and I honestly
really appreciated it interestingly all
of that really stands in stark contrast
to yusuke and Kara's sight of these
events they're their pepy selves heck
there's a recurring gag of kurabara
being head over heels for yukina as they
make their way up to Tan's mansion with
all the confidence in the world they're
Unstoppable taking down toguro's men
without a care in the world what's
fascinating however is that back in
inside the Mansion Togashi is using this
to expand the world tarukane calls in an
entity called the black black Club a
mysterious group of Rich individuals
invited to place bets on how toguro and
his men farare against yusuke and kabara
The Intruders I kind of love the idea of
humans and demons interfacing like this
using one another for profit and
entertainment with the darker
inclinations of humanity acting as the
point that Bridges the gap between the
Demonic forces and the humans themselves
of course the majority B Anto guru's men
winning but there's an anomaly here a
mystery is being set up that I love so
much a mysterious Suave man called sakio
bets on the human pair time and time
again for some reason that's completely
unknown to us raking in millions and
trillions as they once again continue to
completely obliterate their opponents
which brings us to the toguro brothers
versus kabara and yusuke oh man okay
this is good prior to entering the arena
the human pair felt no threat no demonic
Aura nothing and yet when they step
inside yusuke is immediately on edge and
for good reason the smaller of the
togura brothers twists himself into a
godamn human sword good Lord that's bad
enough and
[Music]
then that is some classic you
underestimated my true power battle
shown in type sh nanigans Togashi is
seriously getting to grips with action
runting now and man the pair get their
asses handed to them thoroughly
throughout this fight after all the
bravado early on they are just
completely outmatched for the very first
time like it's not even close however I
was so ready to be upset again at this
point use genar hatch a plan that
involves the ladder launching a raiki
blade at toguro while the former blasts
him with a ray gun to increase his
penetrative power some real badass but
also kind of convenient strategy like
we've seen a thousand times before in
the story and hey it works or so it
seems he shows up to save his sister and
kick taruk Kane's ass kabara gets a
beautiful moment with yukina all his
hunky dory neatly tied in a bow once
again Dam it toosi come on I thought we
were better than this but oh wait I
could not have been more wrong one
chapter later and not only is toguro
alive but he was working for that
mysterious zako all along and through
the fight on purpose this dude gets it
beheads tyuk Kane as it turns out he
stole yukina in the first place from
sakio and then matches off into the
human world after yusuke dude he
literally rolls up on yusuke tells him
he used 20% of his power in their fight
and then forcefully invites him and
kabara to take him on in a fight to the
death Dark Tournament style all the
while flexing 60% of his power H okay
yeah this is such a curveball Chad move
by Togashi and I would absolutely marry
this story if it were human although
those pages do be looking pretty good
right about now he and Kurama are thrown
into the mix leaving a final mystery
single spot in their team and as the
final chapter comes to a close yusuke
arrives at gen Kai's place with sheer
determination on his face he says I've
got two months I need to be stronger
much stronger what a setup I was so sure
this was just another Standalone Arc
like all the rest but I have never been
happier to be wrong Togashi just laid
the foundations of hype with ease This
truly feels like such a turning point in
the story and I cannot wait to see what
awaits Us in the Dark Tournament proper
next time I'm sure much of this video
has felt I don't know a little alien if
you've only seen the anime as I've since
learned that it cut a great number of
these chapters in favor of streamlining
the story's first Saga and while that
may very well be for the best best I
won't personally be checking it out
until I'm done with the manga I can't
say I regret having read them either
there's a real Beauty to seeing a mangaa
evolve with their work and especially
being able to come at it from the angle
of knowing what he's capable of later in
Hunter Hunter in this video I've had the
real privilege of seeing an author
originally only comfortable with comedy
and romance make mistakes with battle
writing and improve across these volumes
I've gotten to see his art evolve with
it and I'm so beyond excited to see what
the future holds now if you excuse me
I've got some reading to
[Music]
do